I manifest specific people
So it's logical
Part 2 is logical.
that all movies on the basis of 5 signs of this
that he is toxic
5 Signs That He Is Cheating On You
5 Ways to Keep It With You
I will skip right away
It's logical that I don't start a fight anymore.
I am no longer a victim and I know
that no one hurts me
and everything is a matter of my assumption
Which in my reality
no one argues anymore
It's logical that I don't have to worry about it anymore.
Will anyone cheat on me
Will anyone love me and so on
because everything is a matter of my assumption
It is logical that if anyone
will come to me for union advice
I won't tell him anything else.
How to Just Change Assumptions